we got this other news update I want to
pull up this story we got this tweet
from Mike Benz I hope you all are ready
for next year he says this is how
self-sabotaging Linda's new crop of
censorship shills are of their own
company
let me slow down there a minute this
guy's pointing out that Twitter has
begun the process I'm sorry X has begun
the process of hiring election Integrity
team members for 2024 which means
censorship they're hiring sensors
he wasn't mention several of these
individuals have previously expressed
interest for the Twitter killer not
wanting to work for uh here says this
guy who's who seems to dream of his own
company being killed or reverted to
Twitter 1.0 censorship even positively
promotes that under Linda they're
getting the band back together the band
of policy team means misinfo policies
he's bragging the old sensors are back
okay
do we trust this Linda what is her name
yakarino yeah is that no
yeah yeah that's her name trust her I
don't know no I don't know I mean it
should be assumed that you just right
off the bat like you assume you don't
trust her now I'm not saying that that
it's not possible that she could earn
trust or that it's pot and it's not
possible that that you know
this could be much you do about nothing
but you don't trust off the bat the
truth is you should never have to trust
your social media you should be able to
verify the code and know exactly what
the media is doing secondly they can ban
you at any time for any reason
everywhere you go so there's no reason
in wondering or be getting angry about
it if and when it happens Linda
yaccarino and Elon Musk can ban you off
X right now I know you bring up like
verifying the code a lot how many I
wonder how many people actually could
verify that like I wouldn't be able to
verify any code like even if they made
the code open source I can't like I
don't know right you might be able to
run it so just chat GPT like an AI
program to like translate the code for
you and let you know what it's saying
well okay
person isn't going to be able to verify
how many how many lines of code do you
think Twitter is I think 18 000 of them
just uh the algorithm so you're still
back to trusting someone to tell you
that oh this is safe yeah so I I mean
it's it's it the reason I bring this up
is because you say you you mentioned you
know verify the code and have the have
open source code and I still feel like
your your average person is still going
to have to rely on someone else that
they trust because they're not it's like
that's like being like oh we'll make
sure that you know put it put it make it
available so that way people can read it
but then like half the world's
illiterate or whatever it doesn't read
that language you would get like um 10
000 developers that all have agreed that
the code says this so it's kind of hard
to have them all lie that they would be
that kind of trust so it's like trust in
the fortification of the mass mentality
I think what would end up happening is
you'd get 80 percent of corporate coders
who align with the Democrats The
Establishment the machine would all come
out and say everything's fine it looks
good to me then you get a small faction
of people being like I don't know this
line of code looks like they're spying
on you and stealing your info then the
corporate press would say far right
neo-nazis claim code is stealing your
info and deranged conspiracy theory I'm
not 100 sure that something just because
of the level of complexity if the
average person can't simply understand
it it might not actually make more
clarity by making the information
available and not saying not saying
they're not saying that that it's a bad
idea that it must be kept secret but I'm
saying that I don't think I don't see
that as a solution because I don't think
that it's go it would make more you know
add more clarity to the average person
it's gonna say I have no idea yeah and
you're gonna get people who will lie
they'll just take a snippet of code and
say this actually does this and then
they could be lying
but when you find out someone was lying
then that destroys their credibility now
look Joe Biden
stated on camera that if you don't fire
the prosecutor knocking the billion
dollars we know for a fact he did it and
they're still saying it's a conspiracy
theory well crazy you're right there was
another story I saw earlier lab leak
theory is still labeled as
misinformation according to these
universities I just hang with developers
and so they they don't lie like they
read code they know exactly what it's
doing and they'll be like yo and then
they make noise about it like mine's the
whole essence of it is free software
code open source code like those are
like my Bros I I would feel very very
good if the code was available to peruse
yes I agree it should be publicly
available more importantly voting
machine software should be publicly
available information and none of this
would be an issue like there would there
would be no indictment they'd be able to
look at and be like okay well you know I
don't know but they keep it a secret
massive private first of all Dominion is
a multinational corporation is it not I
assume so yeah it's International it's
an international company that handles
our elections I mean that just seems
like a really bad idea
yeah like I'm not saying that Dominion
did anything wrong I'm just saying the
United States should sever all ties with
International organizations that handle
our voting and it should be law listen
up Republicans pass this bill the
software code for voting machines should
be public available have a nice day
that's it there's what's the argument
against it yeah I I mean I I have any
kind of issue with it with it being
available
I mean awesome there are people that I
assume that there might be problems in
the fact that it's proprietary like if
you have uh intellectual property issues
with that right too bad go home you
should not be able to operate an
election oh for like fair enough okay
yeah yeah yeah okay I mean you can make
software code that people don't get
access to but you're the election
machine all software on it the code must
be publicly available for people to
review and see sure yeah if there's
little lines in there that let people
flip tallies and stuff uh I'm gonna
point you to what's that guy's name that
a software developer that testified in
Congress that he wrote a program the
flip votes 5149 this is like from the
year 2000. I'll pull it up in a minute I
mean I think like two we're gonna see a
lot of issues in 24 just in terms of
voter trust like there are so many
members of the base out there especially
Trump space that just don't believe that
their 2024 ballot is going to be counted
correctly and that is a massive problem
and Republicans like you said don't do
anything they don't seem to have any
plan to address that we haven't changed
any of these voter laws that the
Democrats switched in the dead of night
in 2020. they're still on the book
seriously there's been like I don't know
who to blame I don't know who to look to
to get this stuff done I I figure Ron
Ronald McDaniel I guess if there has
been no mo no movement no effort taken
by the Republicans to make sure that
they're in a different position uh
strategically for this election then I
mean then all of the talking about
Donald Trump or or talking about
DeSantis or Vivek or whoever all that
stuff is just horse crap it doesn't
matter if the Republicans have not taken
measures to prevent the type of
electioneering that happened last night
that dude let's pass a bill I think Tom
this is Thomas Massey's ball game and I
would love to get Kevin McCarthy
involved I don't know I haven't talked
to Matt Gates I'm sure would love to
hear this any bill that gets passed has
to get through the Senate and through
the president and anything that might
help the Republicans is not going to
happen so you have to think of things if
the if the Congress right now has power
to do things like like affect like uh um
the purse string so like they'll they
cannot fund stuff so if there's
something that they want to affect they
can be like well we're not going to pass
pass a bill that pays for it but if
Congress just passes a bill that you
know is a or a bill that in the hopes of
becoming a law the Senate's not going to
pass it and and and Biden's not going to
sign it so passing a bill would be a way
even even talking about passing them
well also yes state level of their own
elections so the problem is is are
people in various even red States aren't
mobilized this has I think been a
problem on our side for a long time the
left being an activist being political
is almost their hobby are people you
know we do our nine to five we kind of
check out we're not involved in what's
going on in our community at all so I
think that's a disadvantage I think also
we don't have enough lawyers on our side
it seems that they have just endless
lawyers that are willing to litigate and
fight this stuff so I always tell people
like get off the sidelines you have to
run for school board you have to like be
an election poll Watcher do whatever you
can because too many of us are just
totally checked out and we're asleep at
the wheel you think it's cool for people
to run for school board if they don't
have kids
yeah why not I mean if you're involved
in your community absolutely
so you think you think that either would
be less likely to on the right to go and
vote because they feel that their
election would their vote it's not going
to be accounted is that we were saying
I've talked to a lot of people that feel
that way really I certainly I've said
the opposite because you're like I'm
gonna go out and go vote first thing the
first day and paper or whatever but I
hope so yeah I don't know I just want to
yeah I just I hear kind of like
discouragement I think is the
overwhelming sense like I I hope my vote
counts this I hear I hear the opposite
there's there's a meme where it's from
the wildfires in New York and then the
cameras panning past like the
Williamsburg Bridge and everything's
orange then it shows Trump dancing and
then it's and then Scrolls past him and
says don't care still voting Trump yeah
what I'm hearing all the memes are
people just saying whenever they're like
Trump did this Trump did that the
elections rigged whatever people just
say don't care still voting Trump yeah
yeah I'm sure that's what I'm saying
yeah that's the meme I mean if that Meme
holds Trump wins yeah if people are just
like don't know don't Cameron vote for
him anyway I think two they'll be pushed
to act and to vote the more he becomes
indicted or just like has the deal Jay
totally weaponized against him this is
gearing people up for Retribution
they're ready for it I just think I just
think it doesn't matter at all
we saw how bad it was in 2016. it's been
ramping up 2016. the Democrats screamed
until blood sprayed from their eyes that
Donald Trump was a Soviet spy who stole
the election all of the craziest
conspiracy nonsense 2020 Trump and his
supporters believed and screamed the
High Heavens there was voter fraud to
the point where you had many people
saying Trump was secretly still the
president it's insane 2024 is going to
be no different no different whatsoever
I've got the name worse it'll be it'll
be it'll be different in the sense that
it will be escalated this developer's
name is Clinton Eugene Curtis and he
testified uh that he that Congressman
Tom Feeney asked him to build a
prototype software package that would
secretly rig an election to sway the
result 5149 to a specified side he
testified that in front of U.S House
Judiciary members in Ohio and the
YouTube video is called American
election hacker testifies it's by an
account called hack247 if you want to
watch the video he is almost giddy
letting people know thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time